taking them out
making the 17th start of the season it's
four and four
c one and one with a two three five and
173 opponents batting average in the
month of july
badou led off the game last night i
believe it was on the second pitch a
ground rule double
here's the 1-0 smokes one to right
and that'll be played off the wall by
kepler with a bare hand
the dew wants to dig for second he's in
with a sliding pop-up double
to start the night again
well like yogi used to say it's deja vu
all over again
we'll see first and third now for
cabrera
see if they can get two one
double play
miata pitches around the double by padoo
tyler alexander is getting his fifth
start of the season i
uh got a kick at aj's comments pregame
today
he said he's been teasing tyler that
he's not a starter until he goes five
he's an opener
for pitch spanked into left field the
lead-off single for polanco
center field down for a hit palaco will
check in at second so the inning starts
on a promising note with a pair of
well-hit singles
he took ball four loaded up for garvin
now the twins have filled the bases with
nobody out a high drive to left center
field
mitch garber with a grand slam
swinging the bat and doing some big-time
damage
four batters in four-nothing twins
in the opening inning at target field
the right guy up to the plate been
swinging it back
very well with 361 lately
got him a 1-0 fastball something he can
handle with that short swing
the ball being closer to him there's a
no doubter
one and two a liner caught
double play toronto with the catch
and the flip to ostidio and maheda
now here's akil badu who's got a couple
of lead-off doubles in his many nights
kielba do it's a fly ball to right high
and deep and
way back and gone towering fly ball to
right off the cat of
bad of a kill badou man is he locked in
right now and he left this one
right on the corner and but dude did not
let him sneak it by
this is incredible and what this kid is
doing
folks gives you so much hope for his
future
he knew it too
hit a ground ball to short for an inning
ending double play in the first inning
drilled down the line and deep
gone a home run hosta deal's fifth of
the year
and the lead is back to ball we boy
oscar dia
wasn't sure if it was going to get out
or not
and he was hustling around first base
by the time he realized it was out he
had to slow his pace down
and get into that home run trot and that
took until he got to second base
off the deal most of his home runs come
off of breaking balls at fastball's
middle end
pull him for his fifth home run of the
season
foul ball
haas left home plate like that was going
to stay fair
and apparently hit the corner of the
limestone now the tigers are going to
take a look at it
some have hit the foul pole some have
hit the limestone
and it came on this side i believe
of the foul pole taking another look
looks like a foul ball long foul it
appears he's standing at second base
one way or another he's going to end up
at home plate right he doesn't need
he doesn't need to stand there it's a
foul ball and he'll have to come back
and grab his back three and two to haas
leading off the fifth
called third strike and he knew it went
away
short three pitches he's gonna head back
strike out
number five for maeda kiel badu is two
for two
tonight and the rest of the tigers one
for the lobby
on the ground
finally retired two away
backhands it and it's a one two three
six ten in a row sent down by kenta
maeda
tyler duffy is on to pitch grossman at
third
candelario would first one out here's
haas the batter
donaldson cuts it off out there
out there a one-hot throw dug out by
ostadillo
duffy gets the third double play turned
by the twins tonight
he makes a great pitch donaldson with
the quick
throw in polanco with the strong throw
into the dirt just to get haas
you know a team's gonna overlook some of
his defense
scopes gonna have to hurry he spins and
throws out simmons
that's a job well done by jonathan scope
who was playing up the middle
the hardest part about this play see it
deflects and then jonathan has to go
hard to his left
is you're spinning so fast how do you
pick up and throw accurately to the
first base
it's just because they practice it
occasionally he's two down and now
polanco
that's a fair ball it's the sidewall
polanco
is going to take for two reyes's throw
is not in time and not on target
a two-out double for polanco
[Applause]
the 1-1 swing in a pop-up
down the right field line victor reyes
over in
will make the catch as he cruises into
foul territory in shallow right field
rooker pops out he gone three for three
today
the double from polanco does no harm
trying to end a tiger threat in the
eighth
right back to the mound at coulomb
does a nice job again getting the twins
off the field no damage done in the
eighth
now hence will come in with a four-run
lead trying to
make it nine straight for the twins over
the tigers here at target field
missed outside and a walk will load the
bases
eric we know has the power another 3-2
fly ball right field and deep and that
ball is gone
the drama and wait a step forward to tie
it at five
wow incredible at bat
incredible result the first grand slam
of his career this is beautiful
right on the corner perfect swing
goes with the pitch did not pull off he
went
with the pitch that's great focus
great job by our camera guys there
and just far enough
wow get the runner to third base that's
what you want i like my chances with
miguel cabrera
he's made a career out of being able to
bring in that runner from third
cabrera a bouncer up the middle through
into center field
he drives in jonathan scope the tigers
have their first lead of the night 6'5
game still on the line one out away from
a w for the tigers
chopper to short harold castro delivers
the final out
and the tigers down four twice tonight
come back and win it in 11.
[Music]
what a gutsy win for detroit